Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier...
...and welcome to Daylight.
An actual AAA horror game...
...that a lot of people had been eagerly awaiting.
Now, I apologise in advance...
...my voice is a little bit tender today.
So I have to this in a more...
...somber, quiet, calm tone as opposed to...
...my normal, very shouty and bombastic self.
But either way, I am eagerly anticipating--
Oh... no, not a spider!
Yes?
Okay.
My name is Mark.
Much to learn...
Indeed, where am I?
Huh.
Okay.
(Pfft!...)
(...I'm trying to read here!)
Okay.
[read it there ↑ :)]
Oh, no.
Oh, eww. Heh-heugh.
Was that just sitting there in that wheelchair?
That's mildly disturbing.
Okay, so Daylight is actually...
...a procedurally generated game, that is...
...supposedly random in the events.
Maybe not on the layout.
Wait, what?!
That didn't make any sense.
"There I go, where I am"?
I am exactly where I am...
...and I am who I am, but I dunno--
Oh no, I've gone cross-eyed...
[ ↑ ]
Is that Dr. Mercer?
Wasn't there a Dr. Mercer in the... uh...
...Outlast asylum?
Why is there a mushroom sitting on that bed over there?
Okay.
Ooo, I've found a lot of glowsticks.
"Use Glowsticks to search deeper."
How much deeper are we talking about here?
Can I carry up to a maximum--
Oooh. Wow.
I got so more mellow.
Sooo, now we're going to sta-- okay, that's glowing.
That's a little weird.
[ ↑ ]
Oh... well, cool tats, bro.
Yeah, but WHY are they burning into my flesh?!
That is exactly what I'm trying to find out here, because...
...things seems to be a little bit odd,
if you know what I mean.
Anyway, so the game is procedurally generated up to a--
HOH! Hi!
Ummm... Hello?
Why were you there?
I'm trying to be a bit more easy on my voice...
...so if you can not--
Okay. All right.
Huh!
Excuse me, I'm trying to be a little bit more tender...
...ooon my voice. What the hell is happening?
Could you not?
I may have to just give up...
...all anticipation on trying to be quiet...
...because I got my microphone set up...
...a little bit higher volume here...
...so if I scream it's gonna blow everything out.
I don't aim to scream and destroy all your eardrums.
So I gotta try to remain reserved.
Oh! What the...? Oh, that's paint on the ceiling.
I thought that was some arms dripping down.
Well, okay, that was weird.
But was there any point in coming in here?
Oookay. I guess nooot.
Well, I'll just carry on my way then.
Hello creepy painting of a little girl.
A-shugga-shugga-shugga.
[door squeaks]
Squeeeeek.
Was that me screaming like a little girl?
I am--
'Kay.
What the hell was that?
"Once a small fishing ville in New Kipling--"
I'm gonna give up. I'm gonna go back to my normal--
I'm gonna go back to my normal stuff...
...because this is gonna get LOUD, I know it.
[ ↑ ]
Uuuhwell then... aaallrighty.
What was what? I didn't see any-- 'xcuse me!
Why did that go away?
What's happening?
What's going on?
I don't much care for this.
If you wanna stop being a douche any time...
...I would really appreciate it.
Ugh.
This game gave me the heebie-jeebies...
...awfully early on into my playthrough here.
Why is there a dresser with a mirror on it?
What? Why?
Once again, I need to reiterate that I've never played...
...this game before, and-- oh, there's a brain...
What? I didn't find anything!
You didn't give me anything!
Why is that spinning on there?
Ugh, is that following me?!
That's kinda weird. You don't have eyes or anything...
...so it's not really that bad, I guess.
Oh, okay. Oookay.
Oookay, I hear something!
My phone's going all wibbly-wobbly!
Or this machine, am I--
Wanna run that by me again, douche?
SHUT-- there's something there!
There was something there!
You can't tell me there wasn't!
I know what I saw!
What flames?
Oh, I got a flare. Can I get more flares?
What... what's gonna harm me?
Please, tell me!
I would like to knoooow!
Something bad's gonna happen.
Something bad's gonna happen to my butt.
Okey-dokey.
UGH.
[ ↑ ]
Maybe it w--
Maybe it was her baby.
Maybe I don't much appreciate all this stuff happening.
You get out of here with this noise!
You get outta here with this odd noise!
What- what do I- wait, there was something I could use...
...or was there?
Oh! Oh, the door!
Uh, a swirly mist someone left
after going to the bathroom!
Wait...
[ ↑ ]
Thaaat doesn't seem very nice!
I heard something!
The hell do I hear?!
Ugh.
Ohkay.
All righty then.
SHUT THE FUCK--
Oh, there' s a thingy! I know there's a thingy!
I saw the thingy!
Uhhhh.
Okay. COME ON, bring it on!
I'm just too... tough... for you.
God! You know, I was originally worried...
...that this would be a lot like Outlast...
...but this is actually a very different experience.
I mean besides the holding up of the thing--
Oooh, there's something in there!
HelloOo?
No?
No one sitting on the toilet tryin' to scare me?
No? Okay.
A-shakey-shakey-shakey.
All right! So-- oh, there is a tiny-- wait, what?
NO! I wasn't done with that!
Or maybe it just ran out... I don't know.
Oh, god! I thought that was something.
Those... those lights look like eye--
[whispering]
Watch... wash the poopdeck? Wash the lift deck?
What did you s--
[more whispering]
You gonna get me?
Who's gonna get me?
I dunno what you're gonna get...
...but please don't let it be me!
Okay, another bathroom!
Why?
Why am I in these bathrooms?!
What was that? What was that?!
God, I don't even know what I hear!
It's always--
It's always interesting to have a new horror game...
...because they always like to...
...throw different things at you...
...and you don't know what to expect.
I mean...
...with most of the indie horror games that I've played...
...it's oftentimes that things get rather similar, so...
...it's good to have a fresh approach, I guess.
Okay, so... guess I'll go here. Did I not go over here?
No, I was all stopped up.
Where do I go?!
I'm a little bit lost. I can't--
Okay, map.
Okay. Zoom in, zoom in, zoom in.
Okay, so it looks like there was actually...
...and open door over here on the right.
If we go over here... yeah, yeah, yeah-yeah-yeah, okay.
All right. Come on! Come on! Bring it on!
I'm ready for ya!
I'm with it--
Hi! That church--that church! [chuckles]
That chair just fixed itself.
All right. So these...
[ ↑ ]
Okay. All right.
I'm sorry I'm relaxed a bit...
...they haven't actually thrown anything at me,...
...except for that beginning part.
Aaaaand now the music is climbing.
Wait a minute, were those three separate things?
Why the f-- Why the strings climbing up?
Closed it--
Ah!
What?!
Do what now with what?
[ ↑ ]
OKAY, what's with the strings?!
Being a douche to me...
I don't much appreciate it.
Uuh-kay. There we go.
I heard that! SHUT. UP.
I don't want none of it! SHUT. UP.
'kay.
SHUT.
UP!
I don't want... none... can I use it with-- thank you.
[ ↑ ]
Well I guess I AM.
Hello wheelchair.
Uh, just sitting oddly in the middle of... nothing.
'Kay.
What am I doing?!
[ ↑ ]
Th--
HEUGH!
'Kay.
Oh, hi! What is that? Is that what I need?
No!
HAH!
What is that?
Do I want that?
Do I want or not want to touch that?
I'm gonna touch it.
"There's gotta be a key." What are you talking about?
Oooh, that's the locked door.
That's the sigil he was talking about,...
...that I need to bring them.
"Anybody there?"
NO! Don't say that!
Don't say that! Why would you say that?! You're a moron!
What?
Whaaaatever.
Whaatever.
Oh, what do we do? What do we do?
What do we do, I am s--
I AM SORRY!
Okay. Cool.
That's good. I like that. That was good.
Let's never do that again.
What is going on here?!
I don't know!
[whispering]
SHUT UP!
Shut up!
Okay, okay. Come on!
There's gotta be a key, that's what she said.
There's gotta be a key somewhere.
There's gotta be another place I can open.
This looks like it--
Oh, that's just a door frame.
God! What do I do?
Oh, okay. Here, here, here.
I haven't been here before.
Okay. All right. Come on! Come on, come on!
Come on! Come on!
Oh, that fixed itself again.
Wait, I have been here before!
Oh, it's very the same.
Wait a minute...
[ ↑ ]
Well, good. That always works better.
Okay, found a glowstick. I got glowsticks.
That's good for me!
But not good for many other people.
Okay.
The tats on my arm seem to be getting a bit strongeeer.
SHUT.
YOUR MOUTH.
I don't wanna hear none of it.
[tinkling music]
I don't wanna open that door!
"What's that sound?"
Oooh, good for meee!
Oh, this is good!
Oh, this is great!
Why?
Eugh. Creepy.
Huh? Heh?
Is this the key?
Is this the key I need?
I don't have a gl-glogh--
Ooookay.
That's bad!
"What the hell?"
OH NO!
Oh no no no no!
Oh, you don't do this to me!
"Can it be?"
Can it be what?
Why do you sound so cheerful?
"I see you"
SEE WHO?!
OOOH, THAT'S BAD!
OWH, THAT'S BAD!
What happened?
Oh my god, I went insane for a little bit!
Heuh.
Great googly moogly.
I'm gonna assume that this is a key...
...and I'm gonna unlock the d--
Oh, I can't move! I CAN'T MOVE!
Oh, I got stuck on a chair. I'm an idiot.
Aaall right! I got the key!
Can't beat me with my teddy bear!
Little Teddy--why do I keep throwing that...
...up to my face like that?
Okey-dokey.
Key, key, key.
I got it!
I'm a winner!
YEAH!
That's more like it!
Oh, wait a minute, I'm not done?
Oh, I thought I would have--
Ooookay.
Waaait a minute.
"Saving content..."
Why?
Where, how, who, what?
What's going on?
What is going on?!!
I don't knooow!!!
What's happening?
Where am I?
I guess I'm continuing on.
[ ↑ ]
I guess that's what I need to do now because...
...there's no other reason why you would tell me that.
Okay.
Oh-kay.
OH!
[ ↑ ]
Oh, that's another clue of what I need to do, I guess!
I need to stack stuff to go over where I need to go.
SHUT-- woah, hi!
Hello lady!
You uh, look s--
Ah, another note!
[ ↑ ]
Rapid butt loss from...
[chuckles] Rapid butt loss.
Other instances of what?
Goddammit, another note!
[ ↑ ]
Huhh. Can I get a little brief moment without notes?
The notes are... getting hard to read here.
OH GOD, IT'S ANOTHER NOTE!
You read this one!
[ ↑ ]
OSPITA!
Really now?
I guess--
I thought you said they didn't like fire!
I CAN'T MOVE!
OKAY.
'Kay.
Aaallrighty then!
Uuh, this note!
[ ↑ ]
Ookay.
GOD, another note!
UGH!
[ ↑ ]
Okey-dokey.
Who's Patrice?
"Some object can be climbed."
"Boxes with ropes can be moved."
Okay.
I wanna move it!
Okay, I climbed it instead.
Allrigthy then.
'Kay, so I need to move it over there.
Oh, I see. Okay. I got it. I got it. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah, okay, let go.
Stop humping the box and get over it!
Stop it!
Okey-dokey, that was really slow, but okay.
You need a bit more, uh... pep in your step...
...if we're gonna be surviving this apocalypse.
Boop-a-doop!
[screaming]
Yeah, that's good!
I'm glad I did that!
Yes!
No!
Why? Why shouldn't it?
Can't climb that, apparently.
Okay, this box is over there.
Do I need to stack up to go over there?
Ooor I'm assuming I just need to go back.
Okay, whatever.
EHH.
Ah. Ech. Brech-beugh. Brech.
Brech, brech, brech, breeech bech bech.
Okay, okay let go of the box.
Jeeeesus.
Jebberscreepersprus.
Okay, so I can't move it this way, or what?!
What is your deal?
Maybe I-- oh, maybe I just need to move it over here.
God, I have no idea what it wants me to do.
Climb it!
CLIMB IT!
Go over there!
Climb that!
Thank you!
So, when am I gonna get outta here?
That's what I wanna know!
When am I ever gonna escape this heeeell?
Jump! Weeee!
Okay.
So-- oh, I'm back in the beginning. Okay.
I got it. I got it. I got it.
Boop-a-doop!
[door opens]
YAY, I'm free!
I'm gonna escape now, right?
This is where I go home...
...right?
Right?
Glowstick.
Shugga-shugga-shugga.
Shut up!
No! No!
No!
Oh, there was another note back there, I think.
I'll read it. I've read every other one.
Oh, it's just a picture. Oh, okay.
Well, that's... good, I guess.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Can you explain that to me?
What are you talking about?
[door squeaks]
Uhh, okay.
Why am I here?
What is going on?!
How do I get out of this place?!
Oh, I gotta find more remnants?
UGH.
Haven't I been here before?!
Uhh.
[ ↑ ]
Am I this... her... and she that they keep talking about?
Am I the lady?
I am the lady, aren't I?
[ ↑ ]
Weren't you the guy that just said...
...about all the crap that's been going on?
Open! Thank you.
[door squeaks]
Nothing over here...
Oookay. Nothing.
I'm gonna assume that it's nothing...
...until something actually happens to me.
Because so far...
...it's just been a whole lot of nothing.
So I'm not exactly worried about it...
...if it's a whole lot of nothing.
Aaaanybody?
Is anybody--
There was something.
Are you a real something or are just gonna go away?
HUH?!
Yeah, that's what I thought--
YAAAAH! FU--
WAAAH, IT'S REAL!
IT'S REAL!
CLEAR! Suck on that!
Ha-ha!
I got the power of the light!
You run away from the power of my flare.
Okay.
I guess I gotta go up or down.
I know he said something about a boiler room...
...so I'm gonna go downstairs...
...trying to find it, I guess.
Everybody stay back!
I'm veeeery dangerous!
What the?
There's nothing here!
It's just dead ends!
Wait a minute, hang on.
Lemme switch to my, uh--
Oh, I got my flare back? Cool.
Ummm...
Well, that sounds gross,...
...but what's the point of coming down here then?
I guess nothing then.
Maybe he was just lying about t--what the hell?
Is that a footprint on the ceiling?
Whatever.
I mean, now I go upstairs...
...that's the only other way I can go, I guess.
♪♫Hottoro-toro-toroh.♪♫
♪♫Is anybody home here?♪♫
Come on!
Bring it on!
I wanna see some big scares! Big scares!
It just been little piddly scares!
Little itty-bitty not-threatening scares.
I wanna see more!
I wanna SEE MORE!
Though!
[ ↑ ]
COME ON!
I WANNA SEE MORE!
What was that?
'Kay.
That's what I thought!
[ ↑ ]
Goood for it!
I thought that was a thing on the wall I could use.
Okay.
AH-WAAAH! IT'S THAT THING!
NONONONONONONONO!
AAAAH! TAKE MY F-- oh, you're gone.
All right then.
Imma save my flare.
Don't ask me how I'm saving my flare.
But I am.
(All right.)
Left is best!
Shut up.
Good then.
Things are getting a little weirder now.
Things are getting a little-- What is that?
Oh, it's a house in the woods.
All right.
There's a lot of room with nothing in 'em.
[whispering]
I'm sorry!
I apologise for nothing!
Okay.
[ ↑ ]
Farish seems like he's doing...
...a little night reconnaisance...
...when he shouldn't be.
Or he's getting freaky with those nurses out in the dirt.
He gets so dirty, he needs to go and bath, huh?
Is that how this works?
Come on!
I feel like I'm running in circles here!
There's nothing here!
[screaming]
No!
NO!
No, you're a dirty lie!
Yeah, that's what I thought!
Dirty lie.
Maybe you been all around in the dirt.
Damn it!
Argh.
So much time, and finding nothing!
Gimme something!
Flare. God, I got another flare. Good.
Now those shadow thingies...
...whatever the hell they are...
...can't touch me.
"I can't see a thing."
I can see plenty of things!
[shouting]
You're nothing!
You're nothing! You're nothing!
You're a whole lot of nothing!
God, I found a whole lot of nothing!
This is place is just...
...and endless maze of repeating corridors!
What am I supposed to fiiind?!
What am I supposed to FIND?!
[door squeaks]
Ooohkay.
THAT WAS WEIRD.
Where are who?!
I thought there was gonna be someone in that chair!
Wait, what?
Where did they go?
Why does that keep sounding like that?
And why does that sound keep following me?
All right, come on!
Oh. Nothing's actually been happening!
Okay, here we go!
Here we go.
This sounds-- this looks like it's something.
Wait, what?
Come on, no.
Oh, I need to find another remnant...
...before I can go there!
God-dingus-dammit!
[whispering]
Shut up!
Shup up! It's not true!
I'm not one of you!
I'm not crazy!
You're crazy for thinking I'm crazy!
I can't see-- I can see plenty of things Sarah!
Sarah, if you could just get off your ass...
...and start doing some work here!
Maybe we could get to where we need to go!
'Kay, now we found a locked door!
GOD, I just need one more remnant!
One more remnant!
Oooh, it's empty!!
Son of bitches, stop messing with me!
GOD, NOTHING! DEAD END!
I keep founding dead ends and nothingness!
I'm on my last glowstick guys.
If I don't find anything now...
...I'm gonna be kinda screwed.
Uhh... I gotta go down...
Oh, no, wait, I can go this way.
I don't wanna go-- OH, REMNANT!
Got it! Yess!
"They will haunt you..."
[ ↑ ]
OHFUCKINGGODDAMMIT!!!
[noises of fear]
NO! FLARE!
I'LL KILL YOU!
HRRGH!
You son of a bitch!
I am not gonna forgive you for that one!
Ohhohoho.
Ohhohoho!
Okay, I gotta go to the room.
Get the teddy bear!
GET THE TEDDY BEAR!
GET THE THINGY!
Yes please!
Thank you! Gimme, gimme, gimme!
Knife.
[It's a pair of scissors, you big, scared dumbo :)]
Okay.
Ugh.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
You got it, bro!
YOU GOT IT, BRO!
You get outta here!
You stay away from me!
I got a place I need to go!
At least Sarah doesn't run out of sprint juice!
It's like Sarah's been running a bit in her time.
Eugh, get it, get it, get it, getitgetitgetit!
TADAA!
♪♫TATARATARARAAA!♪♫
Okay.
Oooh, found glowsticks.
H-okay.
Let's just take a breather here.
Let's stop up for a second.
Catch my breath.
Maaaan.
I think imma stop this episode here.
But good GOD! UGHhuhhuh.
This game isn't about, like...
Th-the thing I like about this game...
...and... and a lot of people... you know... will...
...might.. may agree with me of disagree with me...
...this game...
...it doesn't just constantly throws stuff at you.
It constantly made me think...
...something was about to happen.
Like that, be all these little things that were happening...
...I was like: "It's gonna turn into something big!"...
...because a-- with all my experience
with my indie games...
...like, there's always like something small...
...and something big...
...that's all is what it is.
But this thing has pacing...
...and it's really cool to see that...
...actually be portrayed correctly in a game, so...
...I'm very excited to be playing this game.
But(!)...
...this is game is designed...
...to be played via live stream.
And I'm not joking about that!
It can integrate with my Twitch...
...and that way it goes to the chat...
...of the Twitch channel, that I'm using...
...and you guys can mess with me!
There's specific commands that you can use...
...to mess with someone who's playing it live.
And I want you guys to have that experience...
...but I don't know if you want me to play...
...the series on my YouTube channel...
...or do live streaming, and take highlights from that...
...and then put them on the channel later.
So I need your help on this one, guys.
I need you to help me decide what to do.
If you guys want me to do a live stream...
...which is kinda what I wanna do...
...leave a like down below to let me know...
...or write in the comments to tell me...
...what you guys want.
So, this is really up to YOU...
...'cause I could do just a normal series of this...
...on YouTube, but I rather get you guys involved with it.
So, let me know!
Anyway...
...thank you all so much for watching!
Click the annotation...
...for more horror games that I've done...
...and as always...
...I will see YOU...
...in the next video!
Buh-bye!
[outro music]